a new report has claimed that long time
Halo developer 343 Industries is being
taken off active development of the
franchise and that new games in the
series will be created by third-party
Studios according to a Halo leaker
bathrobe Spartan who has a track record
leaking Halo inside information
Microsoft's Mass layoffs have hit 343
Industries hard and we'll see up to a
third of its Workforce laid off 343
Industries will then take a parental
role for Halo overseeing new games and
content while working on maintaining the
game's engine this isn't entirely new
territory for 343 Industries as it has
relied on outside help to develop Halo's
multiplayer content in season 2 is a
prime example of this but bathrobe
Spartan claims that the planned story
DLC has been scrapped due to it being
considered not cost effective under 343
stewardship on the flip side Bloomberg's
Jason schreier jumped into a reset error
threat about the report and said quote I
ran these bullet point points by a few
people while it's true that 343 is
focused on multiplayer the stuff about
campaign DLC being scrapped is false I
don't think there was much of that
planned in the first place and a lot of
this is either wrong or just speculation
Gamespot has contacted Microsoft in an
attempt to get more details so make sure
to check out the site for any further
updates and speaking of updates where
are the rest of the big fixes for GTA
the trilogy The Definitive Edition the
bundle of games have broken free of the
Rockstar store exclusivity and are now
available to purchase on Steam this is
great for steam deck owners because all
three games are compatible but not so
great at the same time because these
steam versions are in the same rough
State the game has been in for months
the last major update that fixed over
100 bugs was in February of 2022 with a
smaller performance update in October of
that same year so while this steam
release isn't as bad as the original
launch version which we called a quote
Absolute Car Wreck of creative neglect
in our 4 out of 10 review it's still
upsetting a lot of players who are
wondering why the games are being put on
another storefront and so many problems
have yet to be addressed according to
the press release the trilogy is also
arriving on the epic game store later in
January will there be an update on
updates for that store's release or will
we get another wave of upset fans twice
in one month only time will tell let me
know what you think of today's stories
and we'll see you next week
thank you